so as we watch the news Chase every
trump-related story like Joy Behar
hunting for clown wigs
what's being ignored crime the numbers
in New York City are as staggering as
the victims young old black white male
female and in New York that could all be
one person
the rules being in charge violence is
truly inclusive it's one place where
diversity trumps everything even safety
the stats are bad rapes are up 10 but
that doesn't get any headlines what does
well the raid on Mar-A-Lago the January
6 commission Liz Cheney getting blown to
bits like she was one of her dad's
Hunting Buddies
but taken together these trump-centric
Tales they tell you a bigger story that
your concerns are not their concerns
especially crime frankly unless they can
tie Trump to it they don't give too
about you hell they don't even give a
singular about you
Corey Bush doesn't worry about Street
crime she bills taxpayers for private
security Eric swalwell doesn't worry
about the price of gas he makes his own
foreign
agonized for weeks over whether to raid
Trump's home I know what that feels like
I did the same thing before I rifled
through Bill Hammer's underwear drawer
during those weeks though Garland didn't
agonize over a crime wave so big even
Kelly Slater wouldn't try to ride it out
he's a surfer
but no 12 boxes of papers and napkins
that's the threat to democracy you know
maybe there's a nuclear code in there
yeah right under the box of sporks
behind Trump's old Ab Roller
I bet you 10 bucks that what they'll say
is the nuclear code is really Trump's
Netflix password
you know it's the same with the January
6 commission which focused all their
anti-trump Obsession on one day of
criminal mischief while ignoring years
of violent crime that came before it
they were King Arthur slaying a dragon
every day every week except their swords
were pointed at us it was all for their
own emotional grandstanding and
political aims and what they were
missing at this expense crime monkey pox
inflation the hiring of 87 000 IRS
agents you know that's one for every
illegal alien that snuck across the
southern border this month you didn't
think I forgot open borders did you who
do you think you're watching Seth Myers
but yeah
but yeah we got 87 000 new IRS agents
who are now ready to shoot to kill if
you claim that lap dances are a business
deduction
so much for supporting single mothers
to one person who let their trumped
Arrangement muscle out voters concerns
Liz Cheney who got humiliated so badly
even her Shadow didn't want to be seen
with her
instead of campaigning on the issues
that concern Wyoming voters like fixing
the economy reducing regulations and
invading South Dakota
no Janie used your position to chase her
inner demons but instead the demons
kicked her ass all over the field and
that's a lot of kicking
the last time someone got beaten that
badly was when Dana Perino caught me
putting a clothespin on one of her dog's
nuts
[Laughter]
so bad
thank you thank you
dog torture
but Liz deserved it because she ignored
all the big issues in order to
obsessively settle a score she became as
single-minded as Andrew Cuomo on take a
secretary to lunch week
and now we're learning Biden reportedly
called Liz after her defeat here's how
it went down
[Music]
[Laughter]
Liz look look I'm sorry about your loss
in the Wisconsin Primary
but uh once they become a state you can
you can run again and you know Corn Pop
never quit he once lost a three-legged
race but he came back
to win again that's why they call him
Corn Pop come on man no you called the
wrong list so this is Liz Warren Joe I
didn't call anybody Joe I'm Joe
hey look don't worry Liz Wyoming's gonna
bounce back Wyoming yes lots of great
tribes there okay the Arapaho the sue
sue
Sue who no Joe Liz this is Liz Warren
warrant
wait wait what do you mean warrant
uh Liz I I gotta go somebody's calling
me about a warrant it's probably Hunter
anyway bye-bye
meanwhile crime is still out of control
I can't tell you how many murders I've
read about this past month and I'm not
even talking about the ones cat and
Ainsley teamed up on at several Jersey
Turnpike truck stops
but the media Democrat complex must only
concern themselves with Trump to them
he's the Bloods the Crips Isis aides and
Fox and Friends all rolled into one
crime stats don't affect them the way
the evil Donald Trump touches them and
Trump brings ratings so what used to be
if it bleeds it leads is now if it's
Trump we'll get a bump
calm down cat
but just like Liz there's so much like a
scorned teenager stalking their EX on
Facebook and Twitter it's a political
beef that means more to them than the
actual price of ground beef which by the
way is up 50 since 2021 which makes me
think Trump could do us all a huge favor
and start committing Street crime
do some smashing grabs Sucker Punch old
people in the face toss defenseless
women down Subway stairs that maybe the
political leaders will do something
about these actual crimes because it's
Trump doing it
but what's that say about the Dems well
text me your answer at 1976 ass hats
[Applause]
welcome tonight
he puts the spokes in spokesperson CEO
of electric bike Technologies Jason
Crabb
she has the toughest job pretending to
be kill meat's friend co-host of fox and
friends Ainsley Earhart
she stays this slender to slip out of
handcuffs Fox News contributor tattoo
and he's back and his beard can sleep a
family of five my massive sidekick at
the NWA well Television Champion Tyrese
NC welcome to the show I apologize for
everything I'm about to say
a criminal you must be glad that the
crime wave never gets any attention
right it's all we talk about yes yes and
all of them have a rap sheet of like 100
crimes 41 this morning we covered a guy
they they don't put them behind bars so
you know this is what they wanted they
defunded a billion dollars from our
police budget here in New York City this
is what they wanted they got what they
wanted and the results are predictable
what do you think of my idea that Trump
should start committing those kinds of
Street crimes you know what he
[Laughter]
Jason you run a bit by the way have you
noticed that New York City is completely
overtaken with electric bikes yeah it's
great they went from Zero to Hero at
coven so I love it so I used to I used
to gauge the whole industry by that
every year coming to New York how many
you know electric bikes can I see my
wife didn't love that game she hates
electric bikes but it was fun for me
yeah and they're everywhere now how is
crime affecting your industry because
everybody's getting their shots stolen
including their bikes their scooters you
know what Jesse Watters this hat is to
pay stolen ripped
it was humiliating
people still you got to buy more so yeah
yeah I dig it yeah I can't curse next to
her you don't have to worry about me I
know I'm sorry with all due respect but
I thought I was gonna be sitting next to
Jimmy Fallon this is not Jimmy Fallon
do you have any thoughts perceptions
ideas that you would like to share with
us about this topic
about the crime yeah you need to clean
it up listen I you know I I this is the
least favorite City to come to with my
family and it used to be one of my
favorites right yeah really I mean this
is a great City it's it's electric it's
got all the potential to be something
great we know it'll come back I feel
like it's turning the corner you know
this story was really about uh robberies
are up and you know people walking into
to the Walgreens and taking stuff and
things like that and I actually think
murder was down a little bit yeah and
they killed everybody
well it's a good sign what I can't
understand when you do these stories is
why is nobody doing anything I mean if
you're a man and you see this happening
you see women get punched in the face
you see people get thrown down the
subway why aren't you doing anything
yeah like when do we become it's because
instead we do this and we just film it
and then we forget that we're also like
we could actually put our phone down and
pull stuff do you want to really touch
some of the people that are fighting I
don't I don't care I would beat somebody
we should have like bystanders gloves
what happens is there's somebody
fighting on the on the on the subway
platform and you break it and you get
bystander gloves and you put them on and
then you handle the home the pantless
homeless guy the MMA guy a couple of
weeks ago right he took that guy down I
mean that was great we all love watching
that we should teach all kids MMA no
doubt Tyrus
yeah what you could teach them
yeah I teach ass kicking um
it's not really a science behind it all
my kids not a rear naked choke and and
talk trash while they go to sleep
welcome back good to see you oh thanks
always a pleasure yes what are your
thoughts on this uh you know I'm gonna
be honest man my mind's been stuck on
why would you do that to a dog I don't
I have and I don't know I know your
monologue was poignant and you had these
and but I kept trying to figure out what
is one excusable sentence for doing that
you went to the store and got a
clothespin it's not true it was a joke
oh it's true no one makes that up
anyone who says I need bystander gloves
to be a hero
we're out of bystander gloves
maybe he'll finish soon like
you know
you know what I'm talking about a lot of
people don't want to touch people yeah I
never understood that I never
sometimes presence is enough and that's
what we're missing from the police force
it wasn't it was presence the reason why
criminals didn't do things is because
they would look over their shoulder and
they'd be a patrol car there now when
they see the patrol car they see a
potential opportunity so they go after
the police now because the police are
handcuffed why don't people run in well
a lot of times when a guy sees something
happening he runs in he beats up the
assailant he's the one who's arrested
and then he has people uh the woke
people going after him those are the
guys who don't get out the Good
Samaritans are the ones who don't get
bail because the guy they beat up
checked four boxes so therefore you are
now a white supremacist hate crime
monster who was trying to stop somebody
from being raped that's the problem is
the perception people don't want to take
those risks because they we've allowed
ourselves to believe this woke stuff and
when you see someone who literally
not even walks up to somebody like
attacks from behind yeah gets arrested
and is out in three hours you see the
point where like what's the point you
see you see officers going this is why I
retired I spent my whole day filling out
paperwork arresting a guy and then I
turn on arrest him again and each time
they see him they get Bolder and Bolder
yeah so the only thing that's positive
in this show is that it's starting to
happen in their neighborhoods right it's
starting to happen in the mayor's
neighborhoods and security and security
guards aren't coming to work anymore and
so now they're starting to feel it so
maybe now they'll do something about it
when it happens to one of them yeah you
got to have the their policies and the
consequences come together like what uh
Abbott did by setting the buses of
migrants to New York cat you're a Law
and Order gal
um
just punch him I know no but you were
we've been talking about this now for a
long time and we talked about how unsafe
you felt coming and going to work do you
feel that that's changed at all no
they're getting Bolder this actually
happened last week I don't think I told
you about this cam was leaving to go to
work and and like in the morning you
know and there was a guy peeing on the
side of our building just like openly
like in the sidewalks with his pants
around his ankles and cam saw me and the
guy yelled at him and said are you
trying to look at my
how bold is that that's crazy what did
he say I I don't I don't know was he hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else